[Applause]
all right welcome to Swiss blast let's
plot some smarts sports we got a ton of
sports to blast starting with some hot
NBA news that means it's time to head
over to the wall of basketballs wall of
basketballs here's the hot NBA news
sports did you know the Lakers have a
player named Lonzo ball that's like if a
hockey player was named jacques puck all
right tighten the tuck baseball ports
let's take some calls and that means
it's time to take some calls caller
you're on live with aunty richest sports
blasts sports what's your question hi
quick question I was wondering if you're
happy with your current high speed
internet plan you know that's not about
baseball but it's still a great question
okay that's taller ball question yeah I
was wondering who you think will win the
American League MVP will it be one of
the Boston players or do you think that
Martinez will split collar now let's go
to sports correspondent Conan O'Brien
with a list of quarterback ratings and
all radio stations thanks Andy
here's a list of numbers that could
either be a quarterback rating or radio
stations ninety four point three three
point two four eighty eight point one
four nine two point seven hundred fifty
eight point three or a two point nine
four hundred nineteen point six sports
seventy three point eight four hundred
and thirty nine point nine forts Hejaz
twenty-two keeping it cool with a
Knights get high your ultimate source
for jazz in Miami Beach sports
99.6 Sports fatty - and eSports thanks
Conan you shot that goal out of the park
now let's wrap it up with sports clip of
the week
[Applause]
hahaha wild weight clip thank you :
thanks Andy back to you thanks Tony back
to you thanks Andy back to you thanks
Colin back to you thanks Andy back to
you thanks Conan back to you back to you
Andy well that's our show ports turn in
a few years from now for another episode
of any winter sports glass sports well I
like that Jim Gaffigan here stick around
[Applause]
you